What's up guys?
I'm hanging out again with my good friends Jake and Richie from the Sonic Dad crew.
We're back in the Arizona desert
because we asked you what kind of things you want to see us blast
out of our sonic blaster cannon.
You came up with some pretty creative ideas so today we're taking those requests and putting them to the test.
Lets dive right in!
Our first experiment today comes from Emilpre 03 who says
we should try shooting chunks of dry ice with it!
Well of course we should! Why wouldn't you?
So I went down to the store and picked up 7 pounds of dry ice so we can load these cannons up
and see how dry ice reacts, if we shoot them at water bottles.
Alright, you guys ready?
Ready. 3. 2. 1. Fire!
Woah! It actually worked!
Oh my goodness, that penetrated! Look at that, look at this, this is so cool!
Ok guys, seriously, I did not expect that to go through
but the first time we actually hit it, it punctured the wall right there,
and this thing is filling up with gas
We got carbon dioxide venting out the top, we have the dry ice bubbling at the bottom
and all that gas coming out this hole.
That is cool!
I actually have a couple more water jugs, and we'll go get em', I'll be right back.
Ok, this is exiting!
In 3.
2.
1.
Fire!
Wow!
Its a geyser!
That is amazing! You know, what happening is the carbon dioxide is creating pressure
and pushing the water out. That came out like, uh, a jet fountain there.
Look at how far that sprays!
Its cool that, the spray came right at your lens (camera).
Nice job. Dry ice? Total win!
I'd do that again anytime.
Next up, we got Phantom Ender who says, can you put a pickle in it? LOL that would be cool.
Lets grab some pickles and get busy.
Oh, mine just kinda disintegrated.
*Laughter*
Fire!
*Maniacal laughter*
Nothing but pickle shrapnel.
There's like chunks of pickle everywhere.
Lets do that again!
I'll sell you my pickle for a nickel.
WOoOoOo!
You can see how pickle juice, and pickles sprayed everywhere.
None of that came out incact at all.
Even though I'm pretty sure we shoved out pickles in, like solid.
It's everywhere! It's all over the wall, it's all over the ground.
All it did was knock our jar over, which is pretty much expected but
Look at all this! Its shredded! We got shredded pickle.
You know what that is? That's relish.
It kinda puts me in the mood for a hot dog, which is coming up next! We got hot dogs!
This one here is a good follow up to pickles.
We got David Forslund who says, go shoot some hot dogs!
So David, we're going to go shoot some hot dogs.
These are the biggest hot dog type things we could find. We need them big because we need them to fill the entire barrel.
Look at that, Look at the way it peels.
This, is going to be interesting...
*More maniacal laughter*
Oh, the spray radius on those hot dogs is amazing!
Looks like a nice shotgun effect.
Yummy!!!!
This is goopy.
A meat cannon
Fire!
WOOoOoOOoO
Oh wow!
HO HO HO HO. We got to see the slow-mo on that.
*Even more maniacal laughter*
Wow!
Oh No!
That looks like an incredible amount of power.
Who knew hot dogs could be that explosive?
*Intense thinking*
Before you eat them
Quick update guys. I broke my igniter and I can't get it to work so we're down to Richie and Jake, I'm out.
Next up, Prestyn Chapman wants us to try shooting play doh.
That's an interesting idea, lets go try it out.
In 3, 2, 1.
Yeah!
Woah!
Okay so that was a total fail, but that is our play doh shrapnel everywhere.
We got little bits down here. It's actually looking quite colorful.
We got little remnants of pickle, hot dog, play doh, dry ice.
What is that?
That was pickle?
Now I like this one.
Kade Nelson says we should try shooting one of the darts from our previous blow dart gun project.
That's a really great idea Kade, this time lets try making the darts even bigger.
I got a party hat, I got a framing nail and a piece of chewing gum, we're going to put it all together
and make ourselves a nail dart.
That's one dangerous party!
I'm pretty confident that you can hit this one blindfolded.
OHHHH! Wow!
Oh! He nailed it!
Where did that even go in?
I see, there's that, oh look at that.
You nailed it. Jake!
What an animal!
Nailed it. First try!
Here we go.
WOoOoooOOo
Yeah! That's what I'm talking about.
Woo hoo! Look at that. You can actually still see, the nail dart inside the bottle, poking out the other side
That's too cool.
So nail darts will take on a bottle of coke, how will they do against a piece of wood?
Ah!
Wow.
That was cool, lets go check the damage.
Oh my goodness, look at that.
Check this out guys, that nail dart went straight through the plywood, right up to the duct tape.
Wow. You can see it penetrates straight through.
Uh, that was fun, lets do that again.
Woah!
This way, you can build houses from across the street.
Yeah. That packs a punch huh?
Look at this guys, this is 1/2 inch pine.
Penetrates, without problem.
Not bad Jake! Not bad.
Last up, we got the tootsie roll challenge.
This is gonna be sweet. OHHHHHHHHH!
Last experiment for today comes from Edward Leal who says we should try shooting candy.
In particular, Tootsie roll slugs.
What an epicly awesome idea, lets go give that a try!
Awesome
That is sweet.
Tootsie slug.
That's gross.
*even more maniacal laughter*
Fire in the hole!
What, the heck?
Are you serious?!?
I thought for sure that it was going to stick to the board but it didn't
It just like ricocheted and strands of Tootsie flew everywhere.
Oh well, lets go make another batch.
Alright, lets blast some of these rocks.
Ha! Thats amazing.
For how sticky and gummy that is, it's amazing that it doesn't stick.
Look at that. Roll that around a little bit.
Looks like maybe somebody had their dog or cat out here. Yeah Yummy.
So for this last shot, why don't we use this thing like a plug, and we'll put all the Tootsie rolls still in their wrapper down the barrel
and shoot it out like a shotgun.
*more maniacal laughter*
That was a little worse than I thought.
OOO. Look at this. We've got candy shrapnel everywhere.
We've got candy wedged in the rocks. We've got candy buried in the ground.
We got candy that ricocheted and flew every direction.
Like over here, 6 feet away.
Look, this one actually came right out of its wrapper, blasted straight out of its shell.
So yeah, new way do distribute candy at your birthday parties guys.
Well that was a ton of fun guys, thanks so much for your suggestions.
And for those of you whose comments we chose, check your inboxes, I'm sending you all $25.
And if you haven't checked out these guys yet, what are you waiting for? Click the link in the description, go check out sonicdad.com
They've got a lot of cool projects, they're very ingenuitive, very family friendly
Thanks for joining us for these experiments guys, we'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then.
Everybody is missing, but I'm gonna try and NAIL IT!